mais pour démarrer l'actualité et le
mystère du bébé abandonné quartier de la
Quinière à Blois un mystère qui
s'éclaircit ce soir alors que la mer
aurait été retrouvé 48 heures auparavant
des voisins donnaient l'alerte après
avoir entendu des cris de bébé dans un
appartement façon face aux pompiers un
enfant d'environ 2 ans seul et positif à
la cocaïne comme le révélera un
dépistage les précisions sur place
d'Ellen chapelet
c'est dans cet immeuble situé juste
derrière moi aussi de la rue Jean de La
Bruyère qu'un enfant de 2 ans a été
retrouvé seul mardi après-midi dans un
appartement du 4e étage c'est un voisin
alerté par les pleurs puis les cris de
l'enfant elle laissait en plein soleil
sur le balcon et qui a fini par appeler
les pompiers puis la police
en fait j'entendais l'enfant qui
pleurait depuis à peu près deux heures
de 11 heures à peu près 13h donc ben
j'ai appelé parce que ça m'inquiétait
quoi j'étais père j'ai eu des enfants et
puis bon ben je voulais pas que j'aurais
eu la conscience pas eu la bonne
conscience il sera arrivé quelque chose
donc je me suis dit bon bah appelle quoi
mais je pensais que d'autres gens
allaient le faire et ben en fait j'étais
le premier derrière cette porte non
fermée à clé les pompiers prennent en
charge un enfant sale qui a fait ses
besoins sur lui et qui ne parle pas que
fait-il là sans surveillance le logement
est normalement occupé par un jeune
mineur malien prison charge par le
Conseil départemental dans l'immeuble
les voisins évoquent depuis longtemps
des va-et-vient incessants sur fond de
trafic de drogue
un moment je la connais à plusieurs mois
c'est une vraie toxicoman et il était
même en psychiatrie si j'ai bien entendu
parler fumer de la courbe normal le
petit l'état coté ça fait demi-tour bref
ils sont frottés l'enfant positif à la
cocaïne a été prise en charge par l'aide
sociale à l'enfant sa mère a été
identifiée une enquête pour délaissement
de mineur est en cours